[Music]
Halloween is next week meaning it's time
for a slew of virtues signaling articles
and think pieces on why every costume
you want to wear is racist bigoted or
some evil form of cultural appropriation
allow me to spare you the mental
exhaustion and propose something truly
radical right now wear whatever the heck
it is you want to wear this Halloween
for me it's gonna be the same old
obi-wan Kenobi costume I born for about
the past ten years though this year I do
think it'll look particularly sharp with
my newfound beard forgetting the
specifics of who's offended by what
today the real issue here I'd like to
address is how the set of people who
find offence everywhere are actually
doing something much more offensive than
any costume could ever accomplish this
endlessly outraged crowd are trying to
suck the joy out of every facet of life
from comedy to Halloween it's just one
of the many techniques these control
freaks masked as the good guys used to
whittle down your own sense of what's
right and wrong until you bow to their
demand of total conformity once they can
get you to stop joking stop wearing
costumes you want to wear and most
importantly stop thinking for yourself
it's very easy to manipulate you
socially politically or otherwise it's
also one of the reasons we've seen so
many thoughtful decent people purged by
this hysterical shrieking movement over
the past few years such as some of my
former guests like Brett Weinstein and
Laura Kipnis when conformity of thought
is your number one goal then diversity
of thought is your number one enemy this
leaves little room for conversation
comedy or costumes it's precisely why
comedy seems largely dead right now who
turns on late-night TV to watch a
comedian lecture you about politics come
to think of it who turns on late-night
comedy at all anymore what I wouldn't
give for Johnny Carson to be resurrected
from the dead to actually show these
guys a thing or two you know come to
think of it zombie Johnny Carson
actually seems like a pretty great
Halloween costume
someone make that happen I'll retweet
you once conversation and honest debate
is taken away all that is left
yelling once comedy is taken away all
that's left is lecturing and once
costumes are taken away all that's left
is conformity none of this adds up to
how a healthy society should operate
does this mean that some conversations
are hard to have yes does it mean that
some jokes are offensive indeed and does
it mean that some costumes might trigger
someone absolutely
but we shouldn't trade in the distinctly
human trait of using our minds to talk
to joke or to express ourselves through
dressing how we please just because it
might offend somebody of course with all
that in mind it's up to you where that
line from edginess to offense is this is
what great satirist and comics and
writers have had to deal with for all
time if you get close to the line you
might just trip over it and rightly or
wrongly there probably will be
consequences for your misstep one year
in high school I dressed up as an Amish
guy one of my buddies dressed up as an
Orthodox Jew and another dressed up as a
Catholic priest we didn't do it to
offend anyone we did it because it was
different and in some ways that's what
Halloween is all about we also agged a
bunch of houses and stole candy but
fortunately that was before Twitter as
for me I have no desire to go out of my
way to offend anyone but I understand
why it's important to live in a society
that allows us to do just that so this
Halloween whether you're a [ __ ] nun a
sexy Pocahontas or a good old-fashioned
geisha remember it's better to be any of
those than a mindless conformist zombie
just looking for brains
[Music]
I'm a first amendment absolutist I
believe in only two things completely
the First Amendment and boobs joining me
today is the host of out kick the
coverage on Fox Sports Radio and a man
who has never never been let down by
boobs Clay Travis welcome to the rubric
I'm happy to hear that's the best
introduction I've had in a long time
that is well that is your introduction I
knew there was only one way I could do
it and it was gonna have to be about
boobs you like boobs I do in the First
Amendment both in fact when I showed up
today at your place I had on my boobs
and First Amendment shirt that we sold a
lot of at the eye appearance on CNN and
I'd like to say that it was some grand
viral attempt to create a stir and it's
not like I'm a beyond or above that but
no I I've been saying that for years
writing it saying it's ears and say two
men say it's a women and I certainly
didn't think it was going to turn into
the viral sensation that it did yeah but
it did turn into viral yeah I saw you
were trending on Twitter that's like
basically the highest compliment you
could get these days the outrage over it
so in a second we're gonna show some of
Brooke Baldwin's reaction when you said
it truly did you did you have no sense
that anything was gay because I saw a
lot of people aside you see what he did
there you see he said it on headline
news the day before yeah - a female
anchor I have said it on my radio show
probably a hundred times I've written it
in my columns yeah it was it's such like
it kind of a words that I'm used to
saying then I just went to it because
it's part of a natural argument there
and I once I saw like remember when I'm
doing that show and you'll know this but
I think a lot of people listening and
viewing will not when you are I was
doing that from my home studio so I can
stare like I'm staring at you right now
I can see how you react to everything
that I say but in my home studio I have
no monitor so I don't even know who the
other person is that I'm talking with I
can just hear their voices and I can't
see her facial reactions at all but as
soon as she reacted I knew what she was
doing I knew there was somebody in her
ear saying like oh this is Trump's
America you got to go after this guy
clay Travis he's a misogynist he's a
boar you know you've got it you've got
to put him in his place
and so what I do
for better or worse is when people want
me to like hit reverse and back up and
apologize
I put the pedal to the metal and go
forward full steam so I doubled down I
tripled down I may have even quadrupled
down so once that happened I knew what
she was trying to do yeah I was her
producer in her ear saying you got to
stand up on behalf of all women or
whatever you know some some clearly
artificial reaction on her part I think
yeah cuz it really kind of torpedoed the
entire segment I mean professional from
her yeah well the other guests then sort
of bought in on it too he attends and
then I think you or at least one of your
fans like unearth some of his old tweets
where he said so I mean the idea that
that liking boobs has become
misogynistic yes
shows you how bananas the whole debate
has gone well not only that I mean it's
not like women are surprised at men like
boobs right big business victorious yeah
exactly
cosmetic surgery the Victoria's Secret
has revolutionized the bra industry in
the last 30 years like golf clubs right
a new technology that comes out so women
understand that boobs are attractive to
men right so it's not like it was
somehow like this crazy thing to say and
then she was like I can't believe you
would say that to a woman I'm like I
would say it to a man I better her worse
here in large extreme and my wife would
say this too I talked the same to men
and women and so to me expecting that I
would change the way I'm gonna speak
because a woman is interviewing me I
would talk to her that if you were a
woman right now I'd be talking to you
the same way yeah that's sexism
yeah I tried to treat everybody the
exact same what may not be great okay
Travis an [ __ ] but he's equally an
[ __ ] to everybody if you want to
criticize me for that right you're so
right that's what I used to say about
gay marriage it's like you gotta let
people be equal so that you can treat
them as shitty as everybody else if they
don't have to be as miserable as
miserable as my wife yeah I deserve that
right they absolutely do all right so
real quick we're gonna show just the 45
second or so reaction from Brooke and
we're not gonna do an hour we can't do
it out then but we're not gonna but
let's just watch that real quick and I
just want to make sure I'm hearing you
correctly
vo OBS because as a woman I'm I said
boobs
I believe completely in the First
Amendment and in boobs those the only
two things I believe 100% and in this
country and by the way jemelle has
notice that he went straight to that
yeah you're absolutely right I did
national television and with a female
host I say all the time because it's
true and that's what I do because I like
boobs and the First Amendment which is
exactly what I said
listen listen Brooke I think that speaks
for itself so the fake outrage that's
the interesting thing to me and you
already hit on this a little bit but she
most likely had somebody in her ear
saying you've got to stand up for women
and all that stuff
do you realize what was happening while
it was happening again the challenges I
don't see your reaction yeah I knew you
know when she comes back to me and says
it spells out boobs
yeah like again I had the opportunity to
back up but at that point in time I
meant what I said it's not like I'm
gonna say oh I apologize let me throw
myself into the fetal position and beg
for the forgiveness of the left and wing
America who's perpetually outraged yeah
and in fact I knew that I was in for a
battle and I I've said this before but I
kind of like being in the center of
media storms you know I feel like
there's a certain peace that comes over
you when you're in the middle of like a
and in the arena literally fighting in
the moment yeah I want my reminds me
when I was a kid
Brer Rabbit you know there were a story
like don't throw me in the briar patch
yeah I love being in the briar patch or
you hear pigs like don't get in the mud
with a pig like he likes being in the
mud
I like wallowing around in the mud so I
knew as soon as she cut the interview
short that it was gonna be a viral
sensation right and I've been in enough
of these situations where people choose
sides automatically and they like Oh
clay Travis is awesome Oh clay travis
sucks bravo for CNN CNN sucks I know how
you know sort of bipolar the reaction is
gonna be for lack of a better term and
so I immediately got on Twitter and
tweet it out ESPN just I mean sorry CNN
could've been just cut my interview
short because I said I love the First
Amendment and boobs I remember what the
exact tweet I said was but I sent that
and then I immediately got on the
benefit
having all these media apparatus ready I
immediately got on periscope and
Facebook Alive and told my side of the
story and took it to the next level and
said oh by the way we're gonna sell
first-amendment at boobs t-shirt yeah
and we're gonna donate the proceeds to
breast cancer awareness which just
throws everybody into an uproar right
because and and and then I think I was a
head of the media storm and I knew the
media storm was gonna come and at that
point in time you can't check your phone
you can't even check Twitter it's just
an onslaught but what I did love was I
got a call from CNN asking me to come on
Monday right and so then I tweeted like
CNN's not outraged you know they want me
to come on Monday as well they left me a
voicemail so I played that voicemail the
next day
CNN denies that they left me a voicemail
says that there's no truth to it and
then late that night I get a text
message saying hey this is not gonna
work but I will say this then I've told
this story maybe once or twice but my
wife is downstairs cuz I do everything
out of my out of my house and she and
right before then I've been saying okay
I've got to do this one more interview
it's been a busy week because that had
been a really busy week for us it was
Friday
and I was like we'll be done in the
afternoon we'll chill we'll go out we'll
take the boys out for pizza just have a
chill night yeah and and it's 2:30 in
the afternoon my time whatever it is I
do that hit and my wife just texts me
from downstairs never good when you get
texted by your wife even bother walking
upstairs
do I need to put the house on the market
because my wife's fear my wife's fear
and I think there's probably a lot of
spouses who have lived through this is
that when you're in this middle of this
perpetual outrage machine at some point
the mob wins Yeah right and my argument
is I'm gonna fight the mob for the rest
of my wife I like it I enjoy it I think
they're wrong and I'm right mm-hmm
but I think her fear is at some point
they're gonna come for you and they're
gonna scalp you and they're gonna win a
fight yeah and she when she saw that she
was like this is gonna be bad for you
they're gonna type catch to you as a
sexist they're gonna say you hate women
and my argument was I know that's not
true and accusations are insults and
levied against me that I know aren't
true if you want to say I'm racist
sexist misogynistic whatever else and
call me whatever you want to me I've
called myself worse you know and I
probably get called worse by the people
that did I live with how did that
conversation go with your wife
because that's serious I mean that's
early stuff I get it I understand look
she is prepared we watched and I had a
read to go back and read cuz Howard
Stern's an idol mine so you need to read
what his wife went through imagine what
what life was like for him in the early
90s to me when you're trying to be as
honest as you possibly can people say
they want honesty but a lot of times
they don't really wins do they want the
fluff they want the o.r a sysm is bad Oh
sexism is bad they don't want you to
actually dive into the nitty-gritty of
details and figure out what the facts
are of a situation and I've always said
that maybe this came to me in law school
I remember a criminal law professor I
had who said there are three things that
matter about every case the facts the
facts and the facts and for what we do I
always find that there's so few people
that would actually look at the facts
the original documents of a story look
at the basis for what they're basing
their opinion on and in this world that
we live in now everybody's decided what
they believe and a story happens and
everybody just uses it as an excuse to
justify whatever they already believe
facts be damned and I feel like I'm in
the rarity you're in the rarity you sit
back and say okay let's like actually
look at the details here and figure out
what the story is before we decide
whether it fits our worldview or not
yeah and what's interesting I think for
guys like us and I think that we are
that these ideas at least are becoming
the silent majority is that in our cases
we both are two-time Obama voters I was
a progressive Wars presidential campaign
right so we've done that like it's not
you know because after this what it what
interested me so much wasn't just wasn't
just okay the boobs comment yeah it is
what it is you know what I mean but it's
it's the reaction after the
manufacturing of the of CNN the the PR
team inviting you on then Brooke saying
no he's banned forever but just this
machine versus the guy who was invited
on says a line that he always says but
then you you took the power back because
you're like a periscope the truth I'll
play the voicemail but then you also
have to deal with all the family [ __ ]
and all that and it just it shows you it
there's a certain David versus Goliath
thing that I just love about it it's
totally true and look when I also went
back if you watch that clip the other
guy who was on there claims that he's
offended
what I said has sent all sorts of more
ridiculous tweets and my audience that's
the other good that's a beautiful thing
that is - yeah the people who support us
will love us yeah right and and that is
that is very gratifying because when
you're in the war all the time when
you're in the battle every day it's good
to know there's some people who have
your back
yeah and they may not be able to have
your back in the same public leg that
you or I can because this is what we do
for a living but there's so many people
out there working at companies that
serious jobs that were worried about
being out there in the arena fighting
because they got to protect their family
they got to make the mortgage payment
they got to do everything else but I
think it's it's gratifying to see them
saying hey we support you here but yeah
they went back I didn't do it they went
back and looked through all of his
tweets and started popping me with look
at what this guy said and then they go
back and I find the same thing with
Brooke Baldwin Don lemons on there
talking about how great Kathy Griffin's
Rack is on with her he's coming on to
show his nipples on you know New Year's
Eve she doesn't react at all to that
nipple net Kathy Griffin says nipple
like six or seven times okay that's the
point I nobody came to me from a
journalistic perspective and I'm far
from a journalist I know in a grand
scheme right I have an opinion in but
when you have it the discussion going on
to me where she made the biggest error
is and it was great for me because it
went viral millions of people saw it we
sold you know lots of shirts we were
asked a lot of money for breast cancer
awareness it was all positive for me but
to me where she failed is she had an
opportunity to have a serious discussion
about a substantive issue and when you
react to a word which in no way needed
to be reacted to I was on to the next
argument right it was just part and
parcel of my larger argument she allowed
that segment to be derailed in a way
that it didn't need to be but isn't that
so consistent with everything that this
set of people is doing these days like
if she would have just let it slide or
even just it could have been a
three-second maybe that was the wrong
word kind of thing and then moved on
then this wouldn't have all happened but
what happened after the truth is clay
Travis is bigger so as you said here
the fact remains this all worked to your
advantage because you like being in the
fight you know how to do it and all that
but what does that tell you about just
the general state of media but also sort
of what's happening with the left that
they they so go over the top that they
end
strengthening oh I mean this is what
they're doing with whatever the
alt-right is or the one-time assist
these days are all that is that you keep
building them yeah because you you need
them in a bizarre way
yeah and they need it and they also are
devouring it's like a snake eating its
own tail right the left devours itself
it seems to me is what is going on here
but you create all of these mountains of
oh there look there have always been
racist people like it I go back in time
and say it's amazing to me than in 2017
while we're talking the stock market is
at an all-time high unemployment is at
an all-time low
the per capita income of the average
household has never been higher on an
inflation-adjusted basis in the history
of our nation those are three really
magnificently big facts that should mean
that people in the country are pretty
happy this should be like the late
nineties right like Bill Clinton was in
charge getting [ __ ] from interns
before like you know I wish he hadn't
gotten a [ __ ] from an intern but
stock markets rolling like he's kind of
good he hasn't taken us to war I didn't
mind the it was I was in GW at the time
and George Washington in an undergrad
and one of the guys that I knew this is
a it's really funny it was even funnier
in social media era but he had been
hooking up with Monica Lewinsky
so it's funny like he's think about the
president's election and who he's having
an affair with she's also sleeping
around that same time maybe not the
exact time but with a random college guy
right at least JFK was having an affair
with Marilyn Monroe right like probably
we're probably gonna find out a lot more
in theirs because they're gonna drop the
maybe it maybe that was the reason he
got assassinated but but like at least
he was like with the most famous woman
in the world at the time that's kind of
what you would want to resident to have
an affair with right Bill Clinton is
having an affair with a random girl
who's living in her mom's apartment in
in Watergate which maybe speaks to Bill
Clinton's ability to connect with
everybody
maybe speaks to Hillary Clinton all
sorts of things that could hit but but
to me this is actually a really good
time in the country and so I just don't
buy into this the world of fear and I
think there's so many people out there
that are wrapped up and encapsulated by
their fears every single day right
they're afraid that they're going to be
that there is violence lurking
everywhere and I know murder is up in
the last couple of years and everything
else but I just think it's a pretty good
time to be in America today and of all
the times that I've been in the country
like this is the least racist this is
the least sexist right I mean things are
moving in the right direction and I feel
like the left wing is making it such
that people who might be natural allies
like you or I were ya know on like out
there fighting for things progressive
ideals they're making me take a step
back and be like I don't want to be on
this person side yeah you know if you're
not if you're banning to kill a
mockingbird because the n-word is in it
I don't want to be on your side like
that's not a battle that I want to fight
on your behalf and I feel like they're
alienating a lot of middle-of-the-road
people not just conservatives but lots
of middle-of-the-road people I consider
myself to be a very middle-of-the-road
guy yeah and the left-wing is totally
turned me off so I completely agree
obviously and I consider myself to be
pretty Center and right now I have every
week I have someone in here that I agree
with on some stuff and disagree with
other stuff I've literally never sat
across from someone that I agree with
whatever really right yeah we must be
the Aristotle and Plato of our time yeah
I guess so you you mentioned right
before we started your your wake up
because as we said you worked on the
gore campaign you voted for Obama twice
and all that so donate money to John
Kerry there you go to try to help get
elected a black guy running for the
Senate in Tennessee which you want to
talk about us Sisyphean task he lost a
bob Corker back in I think was oh six so
I'm guessing he did it not because of
his the color of his skin but anyways I
thought he'd be a better candidate then
then bob Corker was yeah and look and so
yeah like I worked in democratic
politics for three years while I was in
college I was on the hill with
Nashville's congressman I'm born and
raised in Nashville Tennessee and and so
I did all of those things I worked I got
fired off of a the campaign to replace
this guy Bob Clement by Jim Cooper
because I wrecked his wife's of although
this is actually a pretty funny story
after my first year that's some serious
campaigning after my first year of law
school I was madly in love with my my
girlfriend didn't girlfriend now wife
and she went off to college she decided
she didn't want to be a lawyer we met in
law school and she went to New York for
the summer to dance with Alvin Ailey
talented
like went on to be a Titans cheerleader
like that's where the out kicked the
coverage phrase okay right ended up with
a girl a lot better than I deserve like
a lot of people probably were watching
and listening right now and and so the
the cut that he wasn't a congressman yet
he was a former congressman who had lost
the Senate race to Fred Thompson he was
running for the Nashville seat Jim
Cooper and so he had a health scare I
actually had colon cancer they found
like a colon polyp or whatever it is and
he had to have surgery and so he was off
the campaign trail
I was his body man I went everywhere
that he went so that was a cool kind of
ground-floor introduction to politics
and so when he went away he was gonna be
off the trail for a week I decided to
fly to New York City to go surprise my
girlfriend now wife spend the weekend
with her hanging out in New York City
middle of a horrible heat wave she was
living in this dingy like you know like
awful like literally like like not much
bigger than this table exactly like a
lot of people who are young and in
college and are in New York City for the
summer so we're up there hanging out and
I flew into Islip because Southwest
Airlines from Nashville was so much
cheaper than flying into LaGuardia or
JFK woulda been
yeah so I flew in to Iceland you had to
take the Long Island Rail Road into the
city who I are right and so I'm going
back on Sunday and that Sunday they had
a massive I think it was like a like a
gas leak and they shut down the LIRR so
you couldn't get to Iceland unless you
had I don't know what a cab cost back
then like $200 there's my them two
hundred thousand dollars and so I had to
take that they turned everybody around
went back I didn't get back in time he
shows up several days early to start
campaigning and at the same time I'd
also just wrecked his wife's car his
wife's Volvo and so they fired me so
that was the end of my political career
I was 23 and and I was but I was working
on a Democratic campaign he's still a
friend of mine but yeah so it wasn't
just that I voted Democratic it was like
I literally gave what I think is almost
the most sacrosanct of everything my
labor
yeah well elected it's so funny because
I said to you Brett before we start I
was like I when I started I wanted to do
what you do I mean I wanted to be like a
sports center anchor from talking sports
all day
now I'm talking politics all day it's
like you were doing more political stuff
now you're talking sports but you're
talking politics all the time baby
Nega intersected I'm sure we're gonna
get to that yeah so inescapable yeah
let's get to that cuz I talked about it
a bunch with Whitlock and Jason Whitlock
and you've really crystallized it for me
because I do I am starting to see this
as a major danger to society I agree
with you on the hopeful in this part
right now I agree there's so much
fertile ground for ideas even the people
who have ideas that are completely
against my 180 fight for them and guess
what they are fighting for them I think
they're the wrong ideas but as long as
we're not killing each other yes I think
this this argument a marketplace of
ideas is good for a mayor I'm all about
that what I do think is actually
dangerous though is the inability right
now for us to escape the fight which is
why I try to take weekends off social
media and all that stuff so but but for
you a guy that's in sports sports to me
is it when sports done right is the most
beautiful thing ever based in
competition and no it doesn't matter
where you're from or what religion you
are it's the it's beautiful beyond just
the black market and the janitor can get
together and talk as equals about sports
in a way that I don't think happens in
any other part of American life today
absolutely or anytime if you just go
play pick-up basketball you don't care
what color anyways can they play yes
they play that's it but this this thing
where they've become so intertwined now
for you you like both so I get it's
probably pretty cool for you but you
think at a societal level that there's
something kind of dangerous going on
here yeah I can't I think I think in
general because I think that what I
talked about before is sports as a
connective tissue that I think binds
many people in this country who would
otherwise have nothing else in common
and I speak from somebody's perspective
who is from the south right I grew up in
Nashville SEC football if you are in the
eleven state football region the eleven
state SEC teams how are in is the tie
that binds the the first book that I
wrote Dixieland delight was about why
people love SEC football so much and it
unites across racial grounds at least in
my generation obviously it was a big
part of why the South in general got
integrated because if you believe the
stories about Bear Bryant he decided you
know what we got to have some black guys
on the team because USC came down to
Alabama and kicked their ass with Sam
BAM Cunningham and the famous line even
though it may not be a hundred percent
true is
in 60 minutes Sam Cunningham did more to
integrate the South than anybody else
had done in 200 years
because people love football so much
they said wait we got to be better and
we got to have the best people
regardless of where they're from
regardless of their color regardless of
their religion anything else yeah and so
I think what's happened is you go from
from there to you know the Michael Sam
the Caitlyn Jenner the Colin Kaepernick
area and we can talk about all of those
but those are all to me things that take
us outside of the field of competition
mm-hmm and Michael Sam is a fascinating
one because I think the NFL is the
ultimate meritocracy doesn't matter
where you're from doesn't matter whether
maybe you can even read write if you can
I'm sure actually yeah if you can get on
the football field and make it more
likely that a team is going to win then
a team will find a place for you and I
think starting with Michael Sam a lot of
people in sports when they showed him
kissing his boyfriend and like I'm a
pro-gay marriage guy right like I am
people I would say like I'm pro-choice I
am you know anti the death penalty like
I could run through all my list right
yeah we should practice story maybe
we'll do that yeah but you know like
things that I don't think necessarily
would you be like the Politico said Oh
clay Travis is a hero at all right I
don't know what that means
but I'm like are that are there tons of
people who are pro-choice out there in
the all right right are there tons of
people who voted for Barack Obama and
all right I mean I think it's a funny
kind of creation of a media falsehood
there but second I saw that headline I
do want to talk about that article for a
second but the second I saw the headline
without even reading it I knew I was
like I know exactly what they're doing
and here we go but let's pause on that
for a second yeah and so I saw it
Michael Sam I said what I saw
immediately was this is not similar to
Jackie Robinson okay because Jackie
Robinson could not escape his race
moreover everybody by looking at him
knew what his race was yeah Michael Sam
more power to him for being gay and
being comfortable coming out I hope he's
having a happy life but the NFL fan
doesn't care about Michael Sam being gay
mm-hmm unless Michael Sam is a great
football player moreover the average NFL
fan doesn't care about Michael Sam at
all yeah if you cover football you cover
guys who make the team much more likely
to win or if you're just a distraction
in terms of your not making the team
more likely to win then nobody's gonna
cover somebody
they're an inherent problem with that
though at some level that if these guys
if no one is out young you're then the
it's incumbent on that someone's got to
do it first right and it's like on some
level should it be the star of stars
who's gonna potentially then create all
sorts of problems for the team and all
that media is up or should it be the guy
that might be about to be cut and then
he doesn't want to do it so there's like
a little bit certainly is a story but I
think the way it was covered it was
covered as if people really cared right
if you were a great defensive end who
had 20 sacks a year then the profile
pieces on Michael Sam I think would have
made sense the fact that he decided that
he wanted to go public with the fact
that he was gay I think a lot of fans
started to say okay you know I feel like
I'm watching the NFL to see whether or
not my team's gonna win not to make a
societal statement and look I don't
think people who disagree with gay
marriage are awful human beings there
are a lot of people in my state who
don't believe that people should be able
to get married if they're gay I disagree
with them but I don't think they're
horrible you know racist bigoted awful
human beings you know I grew up in a
Southern Baptist Church the vast
majority of people who went to my
Southern Baptist Church probably would
have that belief right I don't think
they're awful human beings I know I'm
pretty well you know what you can do is
talk to them yeah them that they're
wrong in the marketplace of ideas I know
instead of brick and rock that's
immediately attacking them right and so
but to me that I opening moment for me
was Mizzou and the University of
Missouri for people who don't know it
this was like kind of everything that I
care about coming together SEC football
I remember being on the airplane flying
back from LA where I was working with
Fox Sports and my Twitter feed blows up
and there's all these people out there
talking about the fact that Missouri's
football team has said they are not
gonna play unless the demands of this
guy who are hunger-striking and the
other black lives matter activists are
agreed to and everybody on Twitter is
amazing just about everybody is saying
so brave of the Missouri football team
so brave of Gary Pinkle to support them
this is a massive moment in the world of
sports we're seeing the power of
athletes raising their voice and my
first thought was okay oh that's fine
what's being protested mm-hmm you know
like I understand why I've been on a
college campus I've been in Missouri
I've talked to those kids there it
doesn't seem like a fundamentally racist
place to me they had a gay black student
body president they had embraced my
Sam it doesn't seem like a school that
has an inclusiveness or diversity
problem so I said okay what are the
issues three things that brought about
this protest one the student body
president allegedly when he was off
campus somebody yelled a racial slur to
him from a red truck no idea who it was
yeah may have happened sucks it happened
no witnesses we don't even know if it
happened but yeah I went to GW right I
went to school Washington DC when I was
on college campus if I'd gone to the the
president of the student body at the
time and I'd said hey when I was walking
off campus somebody came by and I've got
a couple of my Jewish friends and
somebody yelled at me at the Semitic
slur on us you need to do something
about it you feel like that's life you
know like you're in a big city you are
not always gonna be nice to you you know
I wish that nobody was anti-semitic in
this entire city of Washington DC
probably people who hate Jewish people
gay people black people white people
like right there's there's a lot of hate
that exists in the world when you're off
campus that's not my responsibility so
that wasn't one and you just can't
manage all that stuff I mean that's the
other piece you just can't even you
can't manage humanity won't open the
idea that you should go talk to the
president of the school because somebody
allegedly said something mean to you
when you were off campus like all of the
things that the president of the
university has going on yeah I've been
arguing for a while that we need instead
of like all these inclusiveness ideas
and everything else there should also be
a counter example here where the person
who makes the most ridiculous protest
has to walk around with a poster board
that says I'm a gigantic [ __ ] yeah all
over campus so everybody can know like
you had the dumbest thing to complain
about on campus this week well you know
the women's March people like those
[ __ ] yeah right you probably just get a
push no doubt you can just walk around
in the [ __ ] ad and that's ideal so that
was one of the things the other one was
a poop swastika yeah and this is just a
funny in a creation in and of itself
because we don't know like I said before
if I had shown up here and somebody had
shown up and they had been like clay
drives I'm a huge fan of yours and they
had handed me a portrait of me done in
poop I wouldn't be like oh my god this
is an endorsement of me that's a
psychotic thing to do right yeah so we
don't know like when I hear poop
swastika I actually think that's
probably somebody who's not a huge fan
of the swastika and
or how crazy would you have to be to use
your own feces to make a poop swastika
right so this is a mental health issue
more than anything probably and we don't
know who did it right so that's really
the issue that rice because virtue
signaling has has hit that fevered pitch
to the point that people are we know
that a lot of this stuff is hoaxes yes I
mean we simply know happens every day so
it's not have been anybody could have
been a Jewish guy who didn't jewish girl
could have been a black person who's in
the protests that did it right their
mental health issues the third one was
somebody walking through campus who was
not a student said a racial slur they
shut down the University of Missouri
over these three things the football
team said they weren't in a play and so
I dove into all these details I wrote
about it and I wrote about it I covered
it pretty aggressively and I was stunned
that I was the only person in the world
of sports and media who was approaching
the story of the Missouri protests by
actually looking at the facts and saying
you know what I don't think that these
activists on campus who want the
university president to stand up on a
table in the university cafeteria and
denounce his white privilege is really
like when you looked at the list of the
demands that they made and yet these
protesters were covered in such a
positive way that the president the
university was forced to resign and the
overall Chancellor of the University of
Missouri was forced out and since then
enrollment has dropped thirty five
percent the university in many ways has
almost died well that was just a couple
years ago and and to me that was the
first moment for me of really kind of
diving into a media story because it was
in my wheelhouse it was SEC football it
was a Southern University that I was
familiar with it was sports and it was
you know political protest and I said my
god there was no basis in reality for
this what should have happened is the
media should have looked at this pointed
out how illegitimate it was that Gary
pinkles response was actually rooted in
cowardice not bravery that the football
team's decision not to play was rooted
not in an understanding of a other
legitimate protest but just kind of like
a viral form of stupidity mm-hmm I was
the only person saying it and since then
it was like all of a sudden I pulled you
know like the world was like it I like
taking the pill in the made
right I've used you take the red pill
and suddenly you start to realize how
much that surrounds you is [ __ ] and
that was the first story where I really
noticed it how quickly did the rest
disintegrate for you because I've
noticed with people and I actually had a
girl on here who you'd probably really
dig her name's Candice Owens her yeah
Twitter's red pill black and yes that's
our YouTube thing and basically she was
a lefty or her whole life and she's in
her late 20s now basically came out as a
black conservative did a really funny
video coming out to her parents as a
conservative basically what she said is
once once she saw it it crumbled really
quick yeah for me because I try to be so
measured with everything it took a
little while like it was people watched
it happened to me over the course of a
couple years cuz I kept trying I kept
going this can't be this camp it can't
be as bad as I think it is I think
people have seen me evolve yes I'll get
people now who say like oh I used to
listen to your show and you wouldn't
ever be involved in stories like these
and to me what I kind of found was if
I'm not saying it there's not anybody
saying it right that's still what's kind
of remarkable about what I do in the
world of sports is I look at facts and I
talk about facts and almost nobody else
is doing it and so I was kind of a
gradual thing I could point to that you
know the Caitlyn Jenner decision I was
like it seemed to me ESPN I still
believe gave her that award so they
could get an exclusive with Diane Sawyer
they put it on ABC I'm like you know
what I mean I understand the purpose of
heroism I'm one of my family members as
trans like if it makes you happy or do
it hmm but I don't think that to me
bravery requires risk of life or liberty
and I don't think that Caitlyn Jenner
risked either and so the idea that she
was incredibly heroic I didn't
necessarily buy into well she was also
an athlete thirty years ago or whatever
forty years ago basically right like
when I see somebody when I see the
Kardashian on the front row at the ESPYs
I'm like this is a total ratings ploy
yeah Ian's full of [ __ ] in the way that
they're talking about this and then is
this kind of progress that Colin
Kaepernick thing but before the Colin
Kaepernick thing happened
we had the Ryan Lochte story mm-hmm and
to me and in a Peyton Manning story the
Peyton Manning moved to Trainor 20 years
ago and suddenly he becomes an
incredible example of white privilege
and you go back and look at it and the
woman who accused him was
out to watch like she was crazy she was
calling people at all hours of the night
she wasn't a reliable witness and the
example I use is we're in this weird
place where if a minority says something
happened or a woman says something
happened you have to believe them or
else you are racist or sexist let's not
just believe you have to bow to it
forever and so my argument is I'd like
to go back to kill Mockingbird which now
is getting banned in the state of
Mississippi because of you know it's -
it's an insanity all right we're like a
book-burning air almost at times but
it's a kill Mockingbird Atticus Finch
puts Mayella Ewell on the witness stand
and he aggressively questions whether or
not she was raped and as by virtue of
that aggressive questioning we find out
that she made up the allegation that she
was raped by a black man Tom Robinson
the jury still convicts him because
that's the broken system of southern
jurisprudence in a pre Civil Rights era
but it's a powerful moment because
that's why we have an adversarial system
you don't automatically assume that
somebody is telling the truth because of
their race or because of their gender
and we have so swung I believe from an
era where a black guy's automatically
guilty in the south because he's black -
a black guy's telling the truth because
he's a black guy or a woman's not
telling the truth because she's a woman
- a woman's telling the truth because
she's a woman
I think you have to look and this is a
crazy I can't believe I have to say this
not but I think you have to look at the
facts of every individual case I think
that rape happens I think it's awful but
that doesn't mean that I think every
time a woman says she was raped it's
true I think that racism is awful it
shouldn't happen but that doesn't mean
that every time somebody says something
racist happened that you have to believe
it Michael Bennett's case it's
mind-boggling to me that I'm like the
only person who covered Michael Bennett
case and the guy lied about his
treatment by three minority police
officers in Las Vegas and again all
these red pill moments the Ryan Lochte
the Peyton Manning the Michael Bennett
the Missouri the Bennett thing one who
is particularly so because because the
story did the second it all came out
your story just disappeared yes
the media didn't cover what what what
just happened and and I I have what I
would say like Hemingway said you know
writer has to have a natural [ __ ]
detector right yeah and and all
so that you know you see like the
iceberg but you don't see everything
underneath the iceberg well maybe it's
the legal foundation the legal training
also my fascination with stories but I
feel like I can see a story and believe
whether or not it's likely to be true
based on the way it's told and that's
because I think I would be a good trial
attorney right I can sit down ultimately
your storytelling contest who can tell
the more believable story
Michael Bennett's story on its face when
he put it out did not make sense there
are and since we know like what the Las
Vegas police responding to a real
shooting is like mmhmm but there was a
report of a shooting in a crowded casino
and Michael Bennett said that as they
arrived for that report of a shooting
they decided to grab him and harass him
and violate his civil rights because he
was black guy well that didn't make any
sense to me I'm like wait there's a
report of a active shooter in a casino
mm-hmm and these cops who were arriving
on the scene with that information make
the decision to suddenly decide to be
racist against Michael Bennett at that
exact moment while they think there may
be thousands of lives in peril and an
active shooting going on they clearly
thought that he was behaving in a
suspicious fashion that's what I think
at the get-go I didn't know at the time
they were two Hispanic and a black guy I
hadn't seen the videos but that's kind
of I say my life kind of changed in one
way I think when I didn't ride around
when I was in law school I'd encourage
everybody out there who's listening or
watching now follow a cop for a night
just sit in the car with a cop and see
what they go through and I think you
will have so much more respect for the
difficulty of their job and so I have a
lot of respect for the difficulty of a
police job and so when I was kind of
like going through this process I looked
at it then we had the videos come out
everything else
basically he's proven a wire on video
yeah and nobody covers it sudden
suddenly and then this one also is crazy
to me
we praise athletes for saying things
that are dumb right nobody and the
reason why I asked eep talking is if you
give somebody a cookie like if I get my
kid a cookie and tell them they did
something good they're gonna keep doing
it even if they're doing something
stupid right like that's what athletes
are like right now and so every time an
athlete speaks out people praise him
LeBron James said last year every time
his son leaves the house
he worries that he might get shot by a
police officer and everybody's like so
brave of LeBron James to come out and
say this you look at the data
LeBron James his son is five times as
likely to get hit by a train and die as
he is to get shot by a police officer
when he leaves the house if LeBron James
had said every time my son leaves the
house I worry that he's gonna get hit by
a train everybody been like LeBron James
right but people believe fundamental
untruths because nobody actually goes
into the data and looks at it and so all
these athletes and Colin Kaepernick's a
great example Colin Kaepernick drives me
insane the whole Colin Kaepernick
protest because when he started
protesting he was protesting something
that he wanted the government to do
which the government was already doing
he said he was upset by the killing of
mine or innocent minorities by police
officers and he wanted the government to
help make it stop mm-hmm Barack Obama is
the president Loretta Lynch is the
Attorney General there already
aggressively investigating every one of
the Trayvon Martin of the Michael
Michael like all of Michael Brown and
Michael Brown case all of the stories
they're already investigating so the
analogy I use is Obama could have just
thrown Kaepernick under the bus and been
like I'm glad that he's protesting but
you know we're already doing exactly
what he wants us to do the analogy that
I use is basically Kaepernick walked
into McDonald's took in me said that he
at 11:30 said that he wanted breakfast
the manager McDonald's comes back out
says he's not gonna stand up till he
gets breakfast and says actually we
serve breakfast all day long here
already
but you would think that Colin
Kaepernick was Rosa Parks the way the
media has covered him well that's why
also it's so strange to me that people
don't hit on what Jason Whitlock was so
succinct about which is this is all a
business at the end of the day no one is
none of these owners of the teams or the
general managers or any of these things
yes again are there racist people yes
absolutely and we wish they didn't exist
absolutely and we will fight to yes
they're bad ideas absolutely but at the
end of the day if you own something and
your employees are doing things that are
hurting the bottom line whether even if
your
or the protests if that protest is means
that enough of your fans aren't buying
jerseys aren't showing up to games
you're you're a businessman you're
you're not a magical societal you know
puppeteer or something and people don't
understand that and in the analogy that
I use I always try to use analogies
because people understand better if you
because everything has become so charged
if you talk about it in a sports context
so what I say is what would you think if
you had a package coming from UPS or
FedEx and when the guy showed up the UPS
or FedEx package he had on and make
America great again hat and he said hey
hope you vote for Donald Trump be like
man I I don't think it's good for UPS or
FedEx business or he could've had a
[ __ ] hat on he could've said hope you
couldn't vote for Hillary Clinton right
right either direction or if he drove
off and that in their car and they got a
bumper sticker that supports a political
candidate one way or the other if police
officer if you got a pulled over for
speeding and police officer came up to
the window and he said like hey got you
for speeding here's your ticket oh by
the way mitch mcconnell's and ass don't
vote for him right whatever you're
saying right you'd be like it's not
appropriate for somebody in a police
uniform or a military uniform or a UPS
or FedEx or McDonald's or a Walmart to
be expressing political views while they
are in uniform on their job everybody
out there be like oh yeah I agree with
that then why do you think Colin
Kaepernick's should be able to do it
yeah they got especially now in a social
media age players have the ability to
get their political beliefs out to a
larger audience than has ever existed
before people say oh he's a modern-day
ollie oh it's like the 1968 Olympics
Holly was not an employee boxers are
self-employed by and large he was not
being signing a paid to getting a
paycheck signed by an owner every week
and the athletes at the Olympics at the
time were amateurs they might been
representing their country but they
weren't representing anything other than
themselves if you think that it makes
sense for an athlete to alienate half of
his audience of the businessman I think
you're crazy people are ripping Jerry
Jones III think that's pure insanity
ultimately I think it goes back to what
we were talking about before we even
went on most people have no idea how to
get paid today yeah and so I think that
there's a divorce between athletes
understanding that fans ultimately
salary and they pay their salary about
watching their games by going to their
games by being engaged in the overall
storylines and so to me when I saw the
Colin Kaepernick story I was again it's
the red pill moment like how in the
world are there so many dumb people
trying to cover this story and doing
such a poor job of it
yeah and ironically it's not even that
they're all dumb they're just trying to
manipulate other people for quiet I
think they're I think it's that and I
think there's also a genuine fear that
you're gonna get fired yeah if you say
anything other than somebody alleging
racism is a hero I mean I think there's
a lot of white people if you want to
criticize the diversity of the sports
media that if there's no diversity of
thought first of all 96% of people did
not vote for Donald Trump you know the
it's almost impossible to find somebody
who admittedly voted for Donald Trump
that writes or talks about sports and
also there's a lot of white guys and
even if you are conservative in your
mindset there aren't that many to begin
with there is a fear that if you go out
and do what I did if you say these
protesting Missouri students who are
predominantly black if you say you think
they're full of [ __ ] well that means
you're racist why you know like I think
people who are full of [ __ ] are full of
[ __ ] regardless of what color they are
and that's why I look at the facts and
you know sometimes I you know there is
legitimacy behind behind a complaint I
said that I thought Izzy kiyul Elliot
getting suspended was ridiculous did
have anything to do with the fact that
zql it's black had to do with the fact
that the NFL I think had poor evidence
to support his suspension so I go to the
real documents and I look at them and as
a result like somehow I've become the
most controversial person in the world
of sports so I think all this is an
interesting segue to Jamel Hill which
will kind of get us into ESPN in general
and again all these things are so
related from from the what the
individual is doing to the employer to
now the companies and everything else
and we can talk about Trump and all that
but you're Mel is an interesting one I
would love to have her yeah on the show
she's welcome to come on
she said you know this thing about Trump
being a white supremacist now I don't
agree with the premise but I do defend
her rights what she wants of course but
that comes with the risk that you're
talking about your employer may not be
that thrilled then a couple weeks go by
and then she want speech she's actively
telling people to boycott ESPN's
advertisers that is at to me that is as
fireable of an offense as you could
possibly have as an employee of a
company telling the people who pay the
bills they don't it's AI think goes to
an a lack of comprehension about how
you're paid right because ultimately I
understand you guys figure out how the
business model is funded and she said
boycott AT&T AT&T provides 15 percent of
the revenue of ESPN through DirecTV plus
all their sundry other advertisements
that they that they pay to me the Jamel
he'll mess was set in place by a prior
decision which was a wrong one and I'm a
First Amendment absolutist we said
before I love first and Eminem boobs
yeah and I think what's a little bit
scary about the First Amendment and why
a lot of people follow us is in a modern
social media era you even if you're off
your job can be fired for something that
you put on Facebook or that you put on
Twitter or Instagram or snapchat it's
it's an instant from going being no name
at all to being virally famous and
that's a great book you probably have
read it so you've been publicly shamed I
think it was John I I know that I
haven't read it
oh it's so good but a lot of it is what
we live right and so it's fine for
people like you or me because we have a
little bit of public profile so if
somebody decides oh clay Travis said
something controversial and comes after
me well there's people who know me and
are gonna defend me if you're just a
regular person there's probably not very
many people who are gonna defend you it
turns into a mob really quickly and so I
think this is emblematic of larger
society as a whole I think it's a little
bit scary that people are constantly
being judged by what they say on social
media as it pertains to their job I
don't know why everybody suddenly works
in HR in our immediate reaction when
somebody says something you don't like
whatever political side you're on is
that person should be fired right funny
like you do wake up when you look at
Twitter and I'm like alright who today
that I've never heard of before is gonna
be a star is going to either a star
we're just gonna be like you know
publicly shamed or destroyed and
hardened feather
yes but it's her way what was the what
was the decision so the first decision
that was wrong was Curt Schilling Curt
Schilling went on his private Facebook
page when he was not on-air and like I
make this distinction I think some
people follow it some people don't
if Jamel Hill goes on a 6 p.m.
SportsCenter and she says the Rockets
won last night and oh by the way Donald
Trump's a white Superman
and all the supporters are racist she
should be fired yeah because that's ESPN
using their method of distribution to
reach all of their audience and people
go on there expecting that they're not
going to hear about Donald Trump being a
white supremacist and and the same thing
would be true of Curt Schilling Curt
Schilling got fired because he had done
several things the conservative but he
had said he missed shared a meme which
basically ridiculed the North Carolina
transgender bathroom right and it was
like a popular meme on the internet that
lots of people were sharing like
something about like a guy who was
dressed up like a woman like let him use
the bathroom with your daughter whatever
and again I don't have an issue with the
try I think this is a great example of
how we manufacture issues that shouldn't
exist somehow in the 60s the 70s will
write smoove Minh the rest of the 60s
the 70s 80s 90s 2000s 2000 teens people
who are dressed like one sex to use that
bathroom and we've never had an issue
people have been going to the bathroom I
have heard a lot of problems about it
never had any issue the example I use is
we don't have somebody Crocodile Dundee
gender Jackson outside right yeah so
that's a Sheila is it a chance yeah yes
and maybe so and so I don't think his
opinion was irrational I don't think it
was outlandish I think it was certainly
permissible because in his private life
that's what he believes they fired him
for it and I think once they fired him
for that they established there are
private opinions that ESPN employees can
have which don't allow them to have
public opinions on the world of sports
Curt Schilling wasn't fired because he
did a bad job analyzing whether the Red
Sox should change relief pitchers right
he wasn't fired because he said
something on the air that was bad for
ESPN's business he was fired because
people decided to follow his private
political opinions and deem them to be
unacceptable my issue with the ESPN is
not politics it's that they have decided
that only left-wing politics are
permissible
so when Jamel Hill says that the
president is a white supremacist that
his supporters are all racist and that
everybody that surrounds him is also
white supremacists including by the way
potentially his his daughter who was
Jewish and his grand I don't think there
that's wife who is in him yes yes I
don't think there are that many people
who would marry an immigrant and also be
very comfortable with having
grandchildren who are Jewish that are
just fundamentally
human beings who judge based on race
gender religion whatever so when she
gives that opinion they have set the
precedent of you could be fired for a
political opinion they don't do anything
for that opinion they basically wrapper
on her knuckles say she shouldn't have
done that and it clearly establishes
what I've been writing and talking about
for a long time which is ESPN has one
standard of speech for left-wing
political belief and another standard
for right-wing and to me that's
emblematic not just of ESPN but of our
culture as a whole when it comes
frequently to the world of sports media
which I'm in now I don't think you're an
awful human being if you disagree with
the with you know the fact that
Charlotte has a rule about transgender
bathroom right I think it's stupid that
we end up in this debate because again
it's a fundamentally artificial debate
designed to play to the basis of the
left and the right and create conflict
where we don't need it but I don't think
of you having one opinion or the other
there is an awful one I think it's an
artificial construct and I don't think
that ESPN can make the decision oh
because of this we're pulling our games
our all-star game out of the City of
Charlotte and the same thing of the ACC
and all these other sports media
leviathans that did that and then you're
also by the way playing games in Mexico
which has much worse of a human rights
issues and and violations when it comes
to gays EA's got games in China which
doesn't even allow people to get on you
know like the internet and use it freely
we're building or not we but Qatar is
building the World Cup Stadium for
whatever it is slave labor with slave
labor literally yes and also all these
it's not just athletics by the way it's
all these people who are musicians they
come out and say oh we're not gonna play
in North Carolina but then they're
playing in Latvia no no like literally
like then they are playing for Saudi
Arabia which just now allowed women to
drive cars yeah right like it's it's a
artificial outrage machine that isn't
rooted in any kind of reality and I
think sports has become one of the
driving forces of it so how do we take
some of this back yeah that's a great
question and as we were saying they're
taking the red pill yeah yeah but where
does this where does this put you even
politically actually
I don't because if we if we were to go
through a couple of things you can ask
me questions answer everything up
completely honestly no answer me ask me
any question I'll give you the I had you
know I never yes my my guests a question
beforehand but I had no doubt because
that's one of the things that I get
criticized about like I turned down my
own television show to be able to say
exactly what I think right I think the
most illegitimate like you can attack my
beliefs and as much as you want I'm wide
open to that the most illegitimate thing
that people say about me is clay Travis
is just saying that because he wants to
get attention because he's trying to
sell to a Marc no I have literally
turned down millions of dollars to be
able to say exactly what I believe my
ability to tell you exactly what I think
is to me the most important thing that I
do and I'm to the extent like everybody
sells out on some level like I don't
know how many people who are in my
industry would turn down their own
television show so they can still sell
everybody what they think about Game of
Thrones which I was told I couldn't talk
about as well as every political belief
I've ever had
so yeah fire away I mean I think this is
a fascinating well just for the record
I've had at least three offers for
networks for more money than I'm making
and I've said no to because yes as you
said I'm the home studio I have a home
studio
nobody is controlling us there is
nothing in our ear yes it doesn't mean
we're gonna be right all the time
but what it means is we're gonna be real
or at least as real as humanly possible
[ __ ] in America right now that I think
what matters more than anything else
regardless of what you believe is that
you are authentically and what you
believe and that you know people who are
watching this in a conversation between
the two of us I think they'll say wow
like that sounds like a real
conversation that real people are having
as opposed to like you said somebody in
our ear talking for three minutes and
telling us what to say they're creating
artificial debate so I sense that you're
probably right where I am in that I
think you're probably a classical
liberal I don't know that you've I know
you voted for Garry Johnson this past
time as I did to both said yeah a little
checkoff of anything I've ever done I've
had him on the show he's a perfectly
nice guy but he's a terrible candidate
okay again we both went over was that he
was gonna be a lot better than he was
yeah that there would have been a viable
option there as opposed to the two most
hated candidates that have ever been
nominated by major political parties in
our country's history I'm with you
brother okay so so he was a libertarian
yeah obviously
so I sense that you're somewhere between
probably a classical liberal and a
libertarian I don't even think defense
you know diff
so perfectly is that important but you
mentioned a couple a little bit of your
liberal cred so you want to just knock
off a couple pro-choice okay I'm
thinking that you should have that right
if you're a woman to decide whether or
not to have a baby
oh yeah I'm grudgingly Pro I'll even go
further than that I really struggle with
it but at the moment I am pro-choice I
am when it comes to the death penalty
because I've I've worked in the criminal
justice system I think the death penalty
presumes a level of certitude that does
not exist I think it presumes that we
are flawless I think we're all flawed no
matter what we do for a living I think
there probably have been innocent people
put to death for crimes they did not
commit and I think if you or I were
accused of murder we wouldn't get the
death penalty because we're wealthy
enough to afford good attorneys so I
think if you are poor and likely to be
not represented by a quality attorney
you're more likely to get the death
penalty so I think that's an unfair
aspect of it as well
okay so against the death penalty
pro-choice for gay marriage we got that
marriage I am I would say from a like
well wish there was a lot less tax you
know like I am pro markets I think one
thing you learn early on at least for me
when I went to law school and I went to
work at a firm and started representing
big companies I was blown away by the
false and like just crap lawsuits that
are filed all day long every day mm-hmm
there are good lawsuits that need to be
filed against big companies the vast
majority don't and so I am I don't
believe that companies are evil you know
I believe in markets
I'm a First Amendment absolutist I
believe in the marketplace of ideas it's
funny I got a D in first amendment law
when I was at Vanderbilt Law School
you're making up for it you can afford
now it's I never would have believed
that I would end up you know as
fascinated by the law and studying it
now you know when I was 22 it was a
third year 25 I guess in the third year
my final semester I didn't buy books and
I didn't go to class like I was I was
ready to just take the bar exam and be
out and so I got a D on that first
amendment exam but I wish now I could go
back in time and more seriously study
yet because I've ended up doing it as an
adult but I wish I had gotten that found
date I wish I'd paid more attention when
I was 25 so kids out there pay more
attention in class even if you're
thinking like I'm never gonna use this
because who makes a living talking about
the First Amendment somehow probably of
anybody at Vanderbilt Law School I bet I
spend more time talking about it than
anybody
funny right before he started I said to
you that I went to SUNY Binghamton we
didn't have a great athletic program
right which I would have been very into
so I really just smoke pot and play
video games for four years I was a Poli
Sci major so I guess I parlayed that
into something but yeah I I go to these
schools now and I was at Clemson last me
at Harvard two weeks ago and I go to all
these schools and I meet all these kids
who were so in the thick of it figuring
out what they think and we're talking
about all this stuff and I'm like man
you have such a leg up on the world it's
so great it's inspiring well I'm
impressed by the number of college kids
that are like there's a lot of [ __ ]
going on right now yeah you know and and
they're like really kind of steeped in
it because they are on a college campus
right now and they see this like when I
what I call it's like it's not like a
modern-day royalty because you'll hear
like back in the day you you would hear
if you were in England somebody would
say I'm the third Earl Dorchester you
know like they run all the different
titles right as a way to legitimize
whatever their opinion is yeah nowadays
on college campus somebody's like I'm a
you know black lesbian transgender
before they even say their opinion gotta
have a limp - yeah a limp as a black
lesbian transgender male female like
whatever you want to say like before
they get to their opinion I'm like why
do I care about the prelude like is your
argument good or is it bad and we were
talking about this affair - when you get
attacked by an accusation of something
that you know you're not to me I just
kind of smile because it means I won the
argument so when you saw that piece it
was political right yeah so when you saw
that piece as I said I saw the headline
I knew I didn't even have to read it and
I could already see a little bit of
traction picking up and and again as you
said earlier it's great when you have
people defending you yes because it
allows you to breathe it allows you to
move on we could spend all day long it
was a 5,000 there's been it's funny
there's been like daily beast did like a
5,000 word piece on me mm-hm and I
talked to them and then Politico did a
5,000 word piece and I talked to them
what was the title or what did they
exactly say that you're the all rights
hero or something like that now again we
just laid out some of your liberal or
libertarian cred I have yet to hear you
I assume at some point you're gonna
burst that with some sort of racist yeah
but I mean again it's important to frame
it that way yeah because I see this I
mean I've seen it happen to me I've had
several articles written in the same I'm
further I'm further to the extreme right
than Breitbart I mean yeah just abject
dribble
and that's why we lay out what we say
and then it's like they don't be here
don't care people don't listen they
don't care they already have their
preconceived notions and so I mean I
writers I'm talking about the right
after I edit errs yeah they came and
they spent you know like the guy came
and he spent the day with me I start
every morning four people don't know at
4:00 a.m. I get up really early because
I've got an early morning sports talk
show that I do from 6:00 to 9:00 a.m.
Eastern and then I do a show also on
periscope and Facebook live at 3 o'clock
Eastern every day and then I write in
between that time I do all this I'm
fortunate you know like I own 100
percent of my company like like you the
business side of things allows me to be
as outspoken as I am in a way frankly
that I wouldn't be if I was reliant upon
being an employee of a major media
company yeah do you find that you're
able to put these principles that you
talk about into practice for your
business - yeah that's one of the things
that's very cool for me the things that
I believe in yes when I talk about low
taxes and yeah and treating people right
and all of those things those are the
ways that I operate my business so it
makes the views that I talked about
stronger edge yes I don't think there's
anybody that I've ever worked with who
would come out and say a negative word
about me you know that's like my wife
says that I'm unique in that people
attacking me doesn't bother me and it's
almost like if you watch football
defensive backs get burned yeah give up
a touchdown pass the next Drive they're
right back up on the line of scrimmage
talk line of scrimmage talking trash and
you have to have no memory to play that
position
I don't like hold grudges I do I just
kind of let things go I'm very like kind
of karmic in that way and I don't think
you could do my job if you set around
and worried like my wife says you can
get 10 things negative said about you
and you remember the positive right I
mean and and I do think there's a little
bit of truth to that but yeah like I and
I always said if people who know me well
I think I said that backwards or we do
this very differently yeah does she say
that you can say 10 things negative and
you remember the positive or the other
way around me it's like I get 10
positives but I the only one I know I'm
exactly the opposite okay
wow you are doing it doesn't really
register I almost feel like when I do
the radio show it's almost it's my way
of sitting down and getting to have
therapy without actually having to pay
for therapy that's incredible
that's very the reverse about what a lot
of people public people are cuz I have
so many people that come on and talk
about that I forget all the good stuff
and you know it's I don't necessarily
marinate it so it's almost like it's
just noise yeah you know it doesn't
impact there's nothing that somebody's
gonna say to me that's gonna change my
opinion about something and that's one
of the funniest things about Twitter is
I'll make an argument and then somebody
will be like oh did you think about X Y
or Z and yeah I did my wife and you'd be
an issue because she's really smart
obviously too and I would talk about her
with an opinion and I asked her opinion
I might not take her advice and she
would say why did you ask me my opinion
and then not take it it's because I want
to talk to as many smart people as I can
make sure that I've considered every
angle there's a great line for another
Tennessee and I used to say Davy
Crockett used to say be sure you're
right then go ahead it's actually pretty
good advice right I mean like if you
think through everything in a rigorous
manner by the time I go public with my
opinion I've kind of thought through it
so yeah like III think that in general
there are very few people who actually
look at the facts and apply them to a
set of principles
so I defend a Jamel Hill I said she
shouldn't get suspended same principle
that I apply when I said with Curt
Schilling he shouldn't get suspended
most people decide whether or not they
like speech based on whether they agree
with it
colin kaepernick it's the easiest thing
to do we're all for free speech and then
and then somebody says something you
don't like but imagine Colin Kaepernick
takes a knee and says that the reason
he's doing it it's cuz he opposes gay
marriage nobody in San Francisco or on
the left wing is gonna say have an issue
at all if the 49ers cut it mm-hmm right
that's his political speech and actually
makes sense because the United States
flag represents gay marriage being
allowed now whereas the United States
flag doesn't represent based on the
actions taken by the government the idea
that police should be able to kill
minorities with impunity in fact the
exact opposite which is what I said
earlier like he's protesting something
the government's already trying to take
action against so all this said so now
these articles Garrett yeah the
political piece and again people defend
it yes and all that stuff so basically
you're just saying you just got to let
it roll off your back and not do
anything right because I mean a lot of
people asked me about this thing because
I think that there's so many people that
watch the two of us or listening to us
yeah that wanna
in this fight but they are afraid
because they don't have the yeah public
profile that we have or whatever it is
we don't have the the Twitter followers
that are gonna back them up and all that
so I think it's an important thing like
to discuss how we navigate through that
well so I appreciate first of all
everybody who stood up and said that
article was [ __ ] was disappointing
to me is I brought that guy into my
house yep
so you know he spent all day with me I
said I start at 4:00 a.m. he spent all
day with me he saw exactly what I did I
don't worry about what I say cuz people
who are watching and listening this
right now I probably said 40,000 words
you know I've been very triggered the
entire time but I say so much that it's
hard to pull one thing out and say oh my
god clay Travis said this now boobs in
First Amendment might not change because
that exposed me to an audience they
didn't know I existed but I thought let
me talk to my producer on my radio show
and my wife and I think that he said he
chose I don't think I know talk to my
wife for a half hour and he takes the
two most negative things that she says
and turns it into like a story he takes
things that my producer said that we're
not true and he wrote about it and I
think for those people who don't have a
public persona already I feel worse
about a situation like that and I also
feel like in the future as more writers
are writing about me to the extent that
I even want to participate in them I
need to just pull my own phone out hire
a transcript person and let them put
every word that I said on the record and
go read the transcript as opposed to
pulling out because I think you know
this I don't think the average person
does the quotes that you choose tells
more about you frequently than it does
about the person you're trying to
profile so I was hopeful Politico is a
big-name place I thought maybe they'll
do a really nuanced intelligent
portrayal about the conflict between
sports and politics and this guy who has
somehow found himself in the center of
them who used to be in democratic
politics now identify I call myself a
radical moderates somewhere in the
middle which I wish there were more
people like us and I think there are
there are there but they don't get paid
attention to because they're not on the
fringes creating a stir every day and so
I thought maybe this would be a really
good profile and I was just disappointed
because it was lazy it was a profile
that was written with preconceived
notions already in mind but within two
it's watering the bridge and I think the
reason is because the reason why I do
that get involved in those is people
think when they share something and say
this guy's an [ __ ] that all their
friends are gonna agree with them what I
have found is if you go on social media
and you say clay Travis the worst human
being ever seventy percent of people who
follow you may agree thirty percent of
people click on it that we like know
what I kind of agree with a little yeah
what he's saying I might not be saying
it publicly but there are so many people
out there who don't feel comfortable
saying things and then that 30 percent
turns into my allies the 70 percent who
you're sharing like if somebody already
hates me
yeah seventy percent of their audience
probably hate me otherwise but we're
we've grown is not by people just it's
by word of mouth to people who like us
sharing it with their audience right but
it's also by people who hate us sharing
that I do and then some of their people
that they think they're their natural
allies they might even be talking with
you at a dinner party even like I hate
clay Travis but in reality you know
they're they're reading the articles
they might be sharing them with other
friends who are like-minded it's like
you have to hide sometimes yeah and
what's so interesting is that when they
do it to a guy like you and they'll be
like ah he's this all right yeah he's
just whatever then you read the whole
article you can't get a quote where it
actually said any of that and then
actually they do push people more your
way so it really it's sort of this it's
a self self-fulfilling prophecy and
again it just comes back to if you're
attacking somebody instead of their
ideas you lose the first person to
decide Oh Clay Travis reminds me of
Nazis that person lost the argument
right and I just think that that is the
the default of the left now yeah well I
appreciate you not wearing the Nazi head
when it came in and you were just off
the plane and by the way it's cyclical
yeah it'll you know back when Bill Maher
got fired it was if you weren't a
hardcore patriot the right is defending
free speech right now but the great
thing about America is as long as free
speech is protected there's always gonna
be people like you and I who may not fit
particular political disciplines and all
the people out there listening and
watching right now but understand that
our most important right is the right to
disagree absolutely that's how you end
an interview and I feel like why truly
feel
we barely scratch the certificate we had
your whole day with you I mean I really
I mean I love what you do you do great
work I appreciate you having me in
thanks well I feel the same way and it's
like I feel like we just had to do just
like some cleanups next time you're in
LA there's so many other things we can
get into you were talking about Disney
CEO Bob Iger running for president
you've been talking that for a long time
and I think you're all right it's
catching up with it and a whole bunch of
other stuff I know you've run into
crawler I'm doing Carolla tomorrow so
don't know I just don't want overly blow
it yawn yes leave a little free speech
yes for me for moral clay tune into out
kick the coverage on Fox Sports Radio
and follow him on the Twitter at Clay
Travis
[Music]
you